also ich knüpfe jetzt an das an was herr
lesch vorhin schon ein bisschen gesagt
hatte ich möchte mich einfach so ein
bisschen mit dieser frage nach der
einheit von forschung und lehre befassen
und dessen ganzes bis ins philosophische
übertragen
jetzt muss man sich fragen was bedeutet
eigentlich diese einheit von forschung
und lehre
ich habe mal geschaut bei humboldt
findet sich diese wendung einheit von
forschung und lehre gar nicht ich habe
sein werk mal durchsucht
das ist mehr oder weniger das was man
daraus dann gemacht hat aber diese
wendung so einheit wenn sie das eingeben
soviel zum thema digitale
geisteswissenschaften in seinen korpus
ich habe dir alle digital vorliegen wenn
sie da einheit von forschung und lehre
eingeben finden sie das nicht mehr
das heißt das ist natürlich immer schon
eine interpretation dieser einheit und
von forschung lehre die humboldt da
propagiert haben soll
aber ich finde trotzdem dass bald vieles
gesagt hat was in diese richtung geht
und als philosophin und philosoph muss
man immer die begriffe hinterfragen das
heißt jetzt eigentlich einheit von
forschung und lehre also einheit
bedeutet nicht identität also forschung
und lehre sind nicht dasselbe
das bedeutet nicht einheit sondern es
bedeutet ihr sie sind wechselseitig
aufeinander verwiesen sie sind
voneinander abhängig
also vielleicht zum medial fall wir
können nicht nur eine dieser beiden
seiten fixieren in universitären oder
wissenschaftlichen kontexten nur die
forschung und nur die lehre sondern die
jeweiligen seiten weisen auf sich hinaus
also wir werden von der lehre in die
forschung gibt verwiesen und ebenso
werden wir von der forschung auf die
lehre verwiesen ich glaube so muss man
sich das vorstellen
und ich möchte jetzt in diesem ganz
kurzen vortrag ein paar gedanken äußern
wie wir uns diese verweisung dieses
verweisung system von forschung und
lehre vorstellen können die
argumentation wird so sein wie kommt es
ganz sehr darauf an dass wir forschung
und lehre nicht als zustände verstehen
ist als aktivitäten also etwas
dynamisches und wenn wir das als praxis
verstehen auch durchaus als
lebensweltliche praxis als nichts was
ich da so abgeschottet vollzieht oder
was
also forschung nur irgendwelche
publikationen sind das ist immer nur die
spitze des eisbergs sondern müssen
glaube ich forschung im dynamischen sind
verstehen dass das ein langer prozess
bei dem am ende was rauskommt aber das
ist ein statisch und im idealfall
eingraviert in das gedächtnis der
menschheit
aber es hat nicht gemäß also genese und
geltung und wenn wir diese genese
betonen dann glaube ich können wir diese
einheit von forschung und lehre viel
besser nachvollziehen als sehen wir
immer nur sagen forschung ist das was am
ende in dem buch steht und einem
zeitschriftenartikel steht oder lehre
ist der gegenstand der behandelt wird
ich glaube dass mir da nicht
zusammenkommt sondern wir müssen immer
schauen wie wird das praktiziert im
alltag eine dynamik und dann werden wir
sehen dass beides viel enger miteinander
zusammenhängt als es zunächst den
anschein hat also wir kommen von der
forschung auf die lehre und wir kommen
von der lehre auf die forschung und wenn
man das zusammen fasst dann hat man eben
so lehre forschung inzwischen so ein
doppelpfeil ja in der philosophischen
logik wäre dass die konditionell das
wäre dann wieder eine identität das
möchte ich damit aber gerade nicht nicht
sagen jetzt kann man sich fragen wie
hängen forschung und lehre genau
miteinander zusammen ja eine weitere
frage die ich ganz kurz heute an
schneiden möchte ist die ist humboldts
theorie heutzutage überhaupt noch
relevant
wir hatten einige kommentare im vorfeld
dieser tagung
sie konnten ja bei der anmeldung in
einem feld im internet fragen oder
kommentare eintragen und 1 kommentar wir
werden darauf morgen noch ein bisschen
genauer auf ihre kommentare eingehen
er hat hat dieses ideal heutzutage
überhaupt noch seine berechtigung
industrie 40 leere 4 0 oder 3 0 was auch
immer digitale lehre ist das überhaupt
noch relevant oder ist das nicht schnee
von gestern oder nur ein idealer und
diese frage will ich hiermit auch so ein
bisschen aufgreifen humboldts cd noch
einmal ganz kurz hat es schon herrlich
etwas erklärt also die einheit von
forschung und lehre besteht in der
bildung des freien individuums humboldt
geht immer vom einzelnen aus vom
individuum nicht vom kollektiv von uns
wie wir persönlich sind von der person
und von der person wie sie sich selbst
bildet als
sie wird nicht nur gebildet seien sie
bildet sich selbst also autonomie
selbstbestimmung freiheit das ist ganz
ganz großes thema für humboldt stichwort
freiheit freiheit also bildung lehre und
forschung sind jetzt endlich praktiken
unsere freiheit freiheit vorzüge es ist
nichts was irgendwelche automaten
könnten oder die meisten tieren wir sind
auch tiere aber wir sind tiere die eben
freie tiere sind und nicht alle tiere
sind frei diesem sinne wie wir es sind
dann noch mal wiederholte die einheit
und der forscher von forschung lehre ist
kein zustand oder faktum nach dem bolzen
ein ziel und eine enorm
also er sagt nicht so ist es es gibt
hier eine einheit von forschung und
lehre sind er sagt er
es ist ein ziel sollte es sein ein ideal
also eine normative anspruch es handelt
sich um ein bildungsideale
wir wollen dahin kommen dass es hier
eine einheit gibt und da sehen wir dann
eben wieder die tradition vergärung
wollte steht idealismus hat deutsche
journalismus klassische deutsche
philosophie im ausgang an kant und der
idealismus ist im wesentlichen dadurch
geprägt dass er tief menschliche
freiheit sehr groß schreibt jetzt ist
das alles schön dahergeredet ideal und
bildung und freiheit des so
sonntagsreden mäßig also diese begriffe
und jetzt kann man natürlich diesem
ideal auch seine etwas trockenere
realität gegenüberstellen und da wäre
zum einen die opposition bildung wäre es
ausbildung lesch sagte dass in seinem
vortrag die universität macht mehr aus
uns als was wir eigentlich bräuchte also
dieses diese über determination ja da
stimme ich durchaus zu aber wir brauchen
natürlich auch ausgebildete menschen die
spezialisiert sind und bildung hat keine
grenzen das aktuelle glaube ich auch wir
können uns endlos bilden wir erreichen
nie ein ziel
stichwort ideal es ist so eine art
heuristik oder so nach kant wäre so eine
idee eine vernunft mit d wir streben
dahin
ein fixpunkt wir erreichen diese sozial
nicht da waren sind wir denn am ende
unsere bildung anbelangt nie
lebenslanges lernen selbst kurz vor dem
tod würde uns noch manches interessieren
wir können es leider nicht mehr lernen
die ausbildung hingegen erreicht gewisse
ziele auch da kann man natürlich eine
größere perfektionierung erreichen das
ist klar aber eine ausbildung wird uns
dann bescheinigt und mit der können wir
dann etwas tun da gelangen wir ehren ein
ende das ist absehbar dass eine
opposition
damit hängt natürlich zusammen die
ganzheitlichkeit der bildung alles hängt
mit allem zusammen wir werden von einem
aufs andere verwiesen
wir haben am ende 1 1 system ein
verwaltungssystem von inhalten das immer
weiter werden kann kann man sich so wie
es im internet vorstellen
wir kommen von einem aufs andere alles
hängt irgendwie miteinander zusammen
bekommt alles im lichte einer anderen
sache beleuchten und dagegen steht die
spezialisierung
wir konzentrieren uns wir nehmen keine
bezüge meinen blick sondern wir
isolieren ein gegenstand
wir konzentrieren uns ebenso hängt damit
zusammen
diese vorstellung von bildung als etwas
organischem und von etwas was
funktionalistische saturiert ist
funktionalismus input output und so
weiter und so fort das hat eine funktion
ein zig ist es konkret organismus etwas
dynamisches etwas solistisches also
etwas was immer das ganze bezeichnet das
ist eine opposition und nicht zuletzt
universität als geschützter raum als
elfenbeinturm vielleicht manchmal wäre
es ist alltag
das ist die wirklichkeit es ist auch
häufig so eine position die man jetzt
hier ansehen könnte und jetzt könnte man
eben aus diesen positionen einwände
gegen humboldts ideal formulieren
zum beispiel könnte man sagen ja ja ist
ja schön hier die bildung und die
ganzheitlichkeit usw
aber wir brauchen expertentum wir
brauchen leute die hochgradig
spezialisiert sind
bildung schön und gut das kann man mal
in so einem studium generale machen
sowie südamerika ist sowie die liberal
arts kann man mal so fünf semester
studieren
die great buchs kann man lesen die
odyssee und so weiter und so fort aber
dann beginnt der ernst des lebens und
dann da müssen wir hier in der
wirklichkeit fuß fassen und sondern
sofort kann das noch so ein schönes
hobby sein dass wir nebenher betreiben
aber wir müssen eben experten seien
spezialisten für irgendeinen bereich das
kann man ihm vorwerfen das hängt damit
zusammen spezialisierung und
professionalisierung
ebenso kann man sagen ökonomisierung und
rationalisierung brauchen wir wir müssen
unsere das was wir lernen muss sich
quantifizieren lassen es muss objektiv
sich feststellen lassen
es muss schwarz auf weiß vorliegen
wann liegt bildung schwarz auf weiß vor
wie wollen sie jemanden zeigen dass sie
gebildet sind
wenn sie einem bewerbungsgespräch sind
und sich sagen ich bin gebildet und der
und sagt die gesprächspartnerin ja
zeigen sie es mir hier wo sich das
können sie höchstens für hinweise geben
ja also ich habe irgendwie das besuchte
ich war im ausland ich bin weit gereist
und so weiter und so fort aber beweisen
sie dass meine person dass sie gebildet
sind und wenn sie es versuchen würde man
eher sagen sie sind gerade nicht
gebildet wenn sie es versuchen also
widersprechen sich darin gerade
derjenige diejenige die gebildet ist
wird es niemanden als solches zeigen
wollen sind das spürt man eher und das
sieht man nicht an einzelnen akten
sondern eher im kontext also was
realistisch ist wieder das hängt damit
zusammen quantifizierung automatisierung
in der heutigen welt brauchen wir dinge
die sehr schnell effizient vonstatten
gehen die so realisiert werden können
dass wir zurücktreten können dass wir es
der sache selbst überlassen können dass
wie auch von unserer freiheit ein stück
abgeben von unserer autonomie und uns
durchaus auch fremdbestimmen lassen ja
indem wir eben befehls empfängerin
befehlsempfänger werden und letztendlich
ausführende organe werden und nicht mehr
alles selbst bestimmen müssen wir müssen
eben gewissen rollen entsprechend eine
gewisse rolle einnehmen die uns von
außen zugewiesen wird und das ist
natürlich wieder ein stück hetero know
me also das spricht so alles ein
bisschen gegen humboldts idealen
zumindest in der realität sag ich jetzt
mal universität ist auch eine realität
aber in der normalen arbeitswelt
das muss man durchaus ernst nehmen finde
ich und jetzt versuche ich einfach mal
so ein bisschen die frage am ende zu
beantworten was kann uns humboldts ideal
heute noch sagen was kann es heute uns
noch bedeuten in diesen zeiten der
ökonomisierung der quantifizierung auch
der digitalisierung der vernetzung also
ich glaube ganz wichtig ist dass wir uns
öffnen für neue wege also die lehre die
vermittlung von wissen kann uns ganz
verschiedenen wegen erfolgen und eben
gerade auch mit den neuen medien und ich
glaube wir sollten die neuen medien
nicht als etwas verstehen was diese
bildungsideale zuwiderläuft sind
gegenteil ich glaube zum beispiel das
internet durch seine struktur der
vernetzung ist gerade das was humboldt
mit mit bildung meint also dieses
verweisung system wenn sie auf wikipedia
sind gut wikipedia ist nicht zitierfähig
also ich verbiete es meinen studierenden
wikipedia zu zitieren
aber wenn sie mal sich die struktur von
wikipedia anschauen sehen sie ein
hypertext das heißt alle begriffe
verweisen auf einander ist man steht
bleibt nicht stehen
das magma mit wenn sie einmal ein
wikipedia artikel lesen werde ich mit
ihnen dann landen sie am ende wo ganz
anders und sie wundern sich wo sie am
ende rauskommen wenn sie das mit dem
vergleichen wo sie begonnen haben und
das ist für mich so ein bildungsgang mit
bildungsgang meine ich auch folgendes
wenn sie beschreiben sollen wie ihre
bildungskarriere verlaufen ist dann
werden sie nie einen geraden weg
erzählen können und sie werden immer
wieder sagen und dann kam aber dieses
ereignis was ich überhaupt nicht
eingeplant habe
und dann habe ich so reagiert in dieser
situation habe ich das gemacht sie
werden immer wieder auf entscheidungen
rekurrieren die mit ihrer freiheit
zusammenhängen und genauso in einer
gewissen analogie verhält er sich in
meinen augen mit einer hyper textuellen
system wie wikipedia und ich glaube wir
sollten versuchen diesen neuen medien
stärker zu integrieren und darin so eine
ideale struktur aufzuweisen
da ist das internet ein meinen augen ist
paradigmatisch
dann war es mir auch ganz wichtig sein
scheint ist dass wir nicht von der lehre
generell sprechen es gibt die lehre
nicht und es gibt natürlich auch nicht
die forschung ich sagte schon sinn
prozesse aber ich glaube wir sollten
immer darauf achten dass lehre immer
lehre in einem bestimmten fach es gibt
nicht die lehre und dann gibt es da
fällt darunter irgendwie die physik oder
die mathematik usw
wir müssen immer schauen dass die lehre
als methode der wissensvermittlung mit
dem spezifischen gegenstand
zusammenhängt wir können lehre und
forschung nicht einander drin weil die
vermittlungs art immer angewiesen ist
auf dasjenige was vermittelt werden soll
wir müssen die weise der vermittlung an
den gegenstand anpassen
deswegen können wir nicht fremde
methoden von anderen fächern oder
generell auf alle fächer gleichermaßen
anwenden sondern jedes fach hat seine
spezifische kombination von der methoden
es können dann schon dieselben der
methoden seien aber die müssen in meinen
augen anders kombiniert wer den anderen
verhältnissen und wir können sie nicht
gleichermaßen verwenden
das heißt gegenstand und methode
verweisen aufeinander
das meine ich damit lehrmethode und
forschungsgegenstand gehen hand in hand
und ich glaube hier kann man auch sehr
viel erfahrung sammeln das ist eben auch
das anliegen des mich an sozialen
netzwerks hinzuschauen bienen
verschiedenen fachdisziplinen welche
methoden sich am meisten bewegen und man
stellt dann manchmal fest hoppla
die methode die im einfach klappt
gelingt dem anderen gerade nicht dann
muss man sich fragen woran hängt das
hängt einfach ja und das zeigt eben
wieder fach und methode sind aufeinander
verwiesen oder gegenstand zu können man
kann es nicht mehr nur unbedingt auf das
fach generell beziehen sind jeder fach
gegenstand jedes spezifische thema
könnte am ende eine spezifische form der
vermittlung benötigen und mein fazit ist
eigentlich noch mal folgendes was ich
auch schon am anfang kurz angerissen hat
die wir sollten forschung und lehre
nicht als zustand seien als prozess
verstehen dass so kam auch kurzen
kommentar schon zur sprache wir sollten
immer schauen wie kamen wir zu diesem
ergebnis der forschung und wenn wir
dieses dynamische
diesen dynamischen prozess uns genau
anschauen werden wir sehen
da gab es immer erkenntnisse der gab es
mehr erfahrung lernerfahrung auch der
forschenden und wir versetzen uns in den
prozess des lernens des entdeckens und
sind dann am ende gar nicht mehr so weit
entfernt von der leere weil wir sehen
dass wir selbst auf seinem weg den mann
beschreiben kann wie das durch springend
bei wikipedia wir kamen auf diesem punkt
und plötzlich kam dass das kann man auch
bei naturwissenschaftlichen entdeckungen
der albert einstein usw sehen plötzlich
kam das ein zufall und dann haben wir so
drauf geht und sie uns wird es kein
geradliniger weg sondern forschung und
lehre sind komplex irrwege gänge die
aber immer wieder unsere entscheidung
als individuen als frei und wieder
herausfordern und insofern denke ich
dass wir durchaus wenn wir forschung
lehre so formal fassen als ein hypertext
will das verwaltungssystem immer noch
sagen könnte dass humboldts ideal auch
angesichts der heutigen zeit in ihrem
digitalen herausforderungen medien noch
von bedeutung ist das wäre meine these
[Applaus]